ce
martinique guadeloupe nomination en
étuve à se jeter niveau carlao hunter ou
d'assaloum hinson connais tu as portail
chinois ni ron martin et yuko kyokai non
légine atom ou chimie biologique ou au
négatif
bonjour à tous je vous ai dit bonjour en
japonais et j'ai aussi saluer mes amis
japonais qui m'ont beaucoup aidé et
aujourd'hui pour leur rendre hommage
je porte une tenue traditionnelle que
l'on appelle yukata c'est un kimono
simplifiée que l'on porte durant l'été
merci beaucoup
maintenant je vais vous raconter mon
histoire je suis né et je viens des
mornes les mornes de basse-pointe ces
mêmes membres qui ont vu naître
l'indélébile aimé césaire et dès mon
plus jeune âge il fallait mettre la main
à la pâte et nourrir le franc fort pour
mes parents n'étaient pas chose aisée
alors il fallait souvent dire quelque
chose alors je partais avec mon arbalète
de fortune eh bien je revenais à la
maison avec des griffes des merles des
rouges gorges et parfois à la rivière je
revenais avec les cadeaux des crédits
l'été thiery sans oublier sans oublier
la mer houleuse du nord qui nous offrait
ses poissons sans compter et parfois
certains de mes camarades vous venez les
mains vides
à votre avis qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
à votre avis eh bien oui vous avez
raison il faut partager le butin
et c'est cette notion de partage qui m'a
accompagné et morne de basket c'est la
montagne pelée au mont fuji kyoto le
japon mais voilà les années passèrent
nous sommes maintenant en 1998 j'étais
en voyage avec certains de mes amis et
nous étions dans un bus mais juste à
côté de moi j'avais mon sac voilà
j'étais tranquille et puis soudainement
on devait partager ce bus avec un groupe
de japonais alors vivement au brésil je
range mon sac
la tranquille je suis content japonais
passe en fait de moi car on y goûte on
guettera minutes plus tard personne je
dis bien personne n'est monté dans le
bus et c'est pour moi la première fois
que j'ai ressenti ce que l'on appelle le
rejet ou le racisme
ou sectaire et c'est à ce moment là il
fallait trouver une solution et on l'a
retrouvé et bien sous tout le côté droit
les japonais le côté gauche
les martiniquais au centre j'ai vu un
mur un mur
i 2 qui est monté il y avait un mur au
milieu des bus il me fallait l'abattre
ce mur là et bien mesdames et messieurs
je me suis dit bettié si les japonais
réagissent de cette façon c'est parce
qu'il ya sans doute quelque chose à
faire là bas il faut que je parte au
japon pour voir ça de plus près et bien
jeune et intrépide et naïve mais aussi
et bien je suis parti
cette année là j'arrive au japon
imaginez-vous des immeubles à côté une
petite maisonnette des petites
maisonnettes traditionnel juste devant
il ne guérira qui passe avec son
portable
n'est ce pas merveilleux la tradition le
moderne
la technologie en même temps eh bien
c'était ça qui autour et bien mesdames
et messieurs l'année suivante
je me suis inscrit à l'université je me
retrouve dans une classe avec des jeunes
de mon âge
et là encore il y avait encore un autre
problème
les jeunes de mon âge et pourtant je
n'étais pas concurrentiels à
l'international par rapport à mes
camarades et je me suis dis qu'il faut
absolument y remédier à cela il faut
faire quelque chose
alors cette année là avec un partenaire
japonais
j'ai créé l'association jappo martinique
nous avons travaillé tout de suite avec
la martinique
nous sommes venus en martinique avec un
couple de japonais avec leurs familles
et nous avons réalisé le premier mariage
entre deux japonais sous les plages de
tatane ils se sont dits rails
tu les personnes en dry qui veut du oui
et ils étaient en tenue traditionnelle
martiniquaise s'il vous plaît
eh bien c'était une opération tout à
fait ambitieuse nous voulions renouveler
cela pourquoi passer un petit 10 15 des
mariages dans l'année en martinique
pourquoi pas on a de belles quand chez
nous à cet effet nous avons rencontré le
dtn l'office du tourisme de la
martinique à cette époque là nous leur
avons donné un dossier avec beaucoup de
questions auxquelles il devait répondre
et nous sommes repartis sur le japon et
bien pendant 2000 nous avons travaillé
encore nous avons invité le ballet
pom'kanel que tout le monde connaît ils
ont bien travaillé et quelques mois
après une réunion subite
j'arrive dans la salle les membres de
l'association sont là et voilà ce qu'on
m'a dit monsieur regina cela fait une
année que nous attendons une réponse de
la martinique
une année il n'en est rien vu que ton il
ne veut pas travailler avec nous allons
te laisse tomber
catastrophe je me retrouve avec une
association qui n'a ni queue ni tête
où est la martinique qui était censée
être à côté de moi je me retrouve
orphelin et ceci pendant de nombreuses
années
pendant sept ans j'ai dû lire et au
japon j'ai essayé de parler de la
martinique de mon île dans les
universités tant bien que mal dans les
lycées également mais voilà je cherchais
la martinique
elle n'était pas là et un beau jour en
pendant ce temps un bien 2007 j'arrive
je tombe sur un article une annonce et
bien c'est être un concours mis en place
par la chambre des commerces de kyoto
alors je me suis inscrit et bien voilà
je me retrouve dans une salle avec 70
japonais tout mon engagement fla
mesdames et messieurs j'étais visible à
des kilomètres
et bien pendant deux mois nous avons
travaillé sur notre projet à l'issue de
ces deux mois deux prix excusez-moi
trois prix ont été décernés
trois prix ont été décernés mesdames et
messieurs j'ai eu le deuxième vie non
nous avons eu le deuxième puis si vous
70 japonais vous l'avez eue
ouais vous aussi madame est bien ou quoi
pourquoi je dis nous parce que justement
dans mon projet je parlais de vous
justement je parlais de la martinique de
l'économie du tourisme de la formation
des jeunes de la tradition et nous avons
eu le deuxième puis 70 japonais n'est ce
pas quoi et incroyable cela magnifique
et bien mais après tout cela il faut
mettre tout ça en pratique et bien
n'ayant pas d'argent je suis allé vendre
des sandwichs sur le bord des routes au
japon sur le bord des chemins
j'étais ventes des sandwiches lambi coin
hareng saur
j'obtiens mais s'attend demain et jeudi
ce qu'il y ait des enquêtes j'en ai
récolté 200 et avec tout ce pactole eh
bien je suis allé à la banque je voulais
faire un prêt mesdames et messieurs
j'arrive à la banque avec mon dossier
les banquiers des innocents qui comme a
pris dimanche la cour les oranais iq et
l'automation collègues à aucun niveau
hockey ada et une taille qui a converti
en deux ans sur les galets bas monde et
non
vous avez entendu ce qu'il a dit
mesdames et messieurs ce gars est génial
enfin pour ceux qui n'ont pas compris
il a dit que j'ai bien travaillé que je
suis un gars sait rien côté argent nos
problèmes en mai qu'il me faut un
contrat de bail
ah mais c'est dans la poche trouver un
local à kyoto il y en a beaucoup et j'en
ai cherché et je vous dis je vous ai
trouvé beaucoup d'espoir et beaucoup de
désespoir car après chaque local trouver
30 minutes plus tard on me téléphonait
monsieur regina
nous sommes désolé car il ya des travaux
à faire vous n'aurez pas le local ou
bien quelqu'un d'autre a déjà le contrat
moi qui ne suis pas dupe
j'ai fait la relation tout de suite ne
pas pouvoir lui un local est ma couleur
de peau est alors il me restait ce
dernier local là bas je me rappelle de
ça comme si c'était hier
ce dernier le qualité là à 100 m j'étais
dans la voiture à côté de moi ma
collègue ce dernier local juste devant
il y avait déjà le propriétaire qui nous
attendait je ne pouvais pas m'accrocher
alors j'ai dû garer la voiture et j'ai
dû prendre une décision
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai dû me
transcender j'ai dû et c'est le siège de
la voiture afin de cacher ma couleur de
poids j'étais couché
je me suis effacé je regardais ma
collègue je regarde un silence
assourdissant
elle est descendue et elle a été
négociée et pendant qu'elle négociait
j'étais en communication téléphonique
avec elle et je lui ai demandé de leur
dire est ce qu'il est ce que tu peux
mettre le nom de quelqu'un d'autre sur
le contrat ils ont dit oui
elle a écrit jean la france soir ne
sacrifices à payer et c'est comme ça
mesdames et messieurs
c'est comme ça que nous avons eu la
première maison de la martinique en
plein coeur de kyoto en face du jardin
impérial l'emploi est passé de vos trois
fois trois fois trois fois il est passé
oui
mesdames et messieurs nous sommes
maintenant en 2010 et nous avons
travaillé
l'association jappo martinique devint
l'association japon martinique
guadeloupe
mais oui il faut que la belle double
soit de la partie et nous avons réalisé
avec un partenaire le festival du roman
le festival du web du nord au sud
pendant cinq ans j'étais le présentateur
officiel
cela sous-entend que l'association jappo
martinez guadeloupe participe au
développement économique de la
martinique de la guadeloupe et de marie
galante donc un travail monstrueux
génial et tout moment ce n'est pas lady
- même à la télé à la tire et tout était
clean
la martinique est aussi visible par tous
les festivals du monde
vraiment c'était quelque chose des
japonais et mes bois où notre homme
alors je vous assure
et voilà nous sommes en 2013 en 2013 une
année particulière car nous avons
réalisé l'année césaire en collaboration
avec la ville de kyoto et nous avons
invité le groupe bélier a que tout le
monde connaît ils ont fait un travail
remarquable est la chose la plus
importante la plus importante
ma première stagiaires qui vient de la
martinique
je les place et la formation
professionnelle dans une autre vie
japonaise elle nous a tous représentés
mesdames et messieurs cette fille elle
vous a représenté vous vous et moi même
elle a fait un travail remarquable et
maintenant elle est en master à
valenciennes tu perds rien à dire 2015
mesdames et messieurs je vous présente
j'imagine japan co pour les jeunes c'est
une société que j'ai créée cette année
qui permet justement de placer nos
étudiants en formation professionnelle
dans les entreprises japonaises à
l'international
cette entreprise mise à part mise à part
justement la formation professionnelle
j'ai mis en place des modules dead afin
d'aider nos étudiants afin de les
accompagner
et c'est justement là maintenant didier
pour ma petite île l'accompagnement
justement il faut accompagner les jeunes
dès la martinique
il faut faire quelque chose donc moi de
mon côté j'ai mis en place des modules
mes élèves je dirais les étudiants de la
martinique ont maintenant des cours de
japonais dispensés à l'université acquis
au tour j'ai mis en place une aide
financière pour les étudiants qui
pourrait avoir un petit pépin sur place
l'énergie au direct en famille d'accueil
afin de parler mieux le japonais tout ça
est mis en place au japon pour que ses
étudiants puisque réussir
des étudiants souriant pareil n'est ce
pas joli eh bien oui hein
mesdames et messieurs j'imagine
j'appelle c'est aussi beaucoup plus de
partenaires et pour encore mieux les
accompagner
je suis monté encore d'un cran de
plusieurs crans en fait car avec deux
autres partenaires en 2016
je vais construire un bâtiment de trois
étages à kyoto c'est comme deux
personnes pourront loger
cela veut dire quoi cela veut dire que
nos étudiants en venant au japon
n'auront pas à se cacher dans une
voiture pour trouver un local
et en plus de ça
quand nos étudiants viennent au japon
c'est un même qui m'aident justement à
casser c'est nous qui avait dans le bus
mesdames et messieurs imaginez cette
montagne vous la voyez cette montagne
est bien peu importe les difficultés que
j'ai eue pour la gravir vous vous
n'aurez pas le faire quand vous êtes
déjà au sommet et quand vous regardez là
bas vous verrez justement une petite
fenêtre et bien c'est le japon c'est
nous qui le côté et quand vous voulez
mais traversée il y à une route
justement jusqu'à cette fenêtre c'est
l'autoroute qui est là que j'ai déjà mis
en place et si vous trébuchez je
viendrai vous ramassez c'est ça
l'accompagnement à l'hiver ton voisin m
ht merci beaucoup
mais
nous